chaotic body camera video shows what led
up to a deadly shooting in a Family
Dollar parking lot after Texas police
officers approach a stolen vehicle
stop stop
[Music]
on April 11th Houston police officer
Kate Cummins was on patrol when he
noticed a stolen Honda parked at a
Family Dollar on the city's South Side
Body camera video shows Cummins pull his
squad car directly behind the stolen
vehicle before getting out and
approaching the driver
Cummins tells the suspect later
identified as Jamar vantrell Thompson to
get out of the vehicle
do not move do you understand
step out when Commons explains the
vehicle is stolen Thompson says he's
tripping
because you get rid of stolen vehicle
turn the vehicle off
Thompson then throws the car in reverse
and Rams into the parked squad car after
that he and Cummins get into a physical
brawl even knocking down a woman
standing in the parking lot
[Music]
stop stop
the pair then wrestle on the ground
during this time the woman in the
parking lot identified as 35 year old
Danica Abraham ended up with cummins's
Taser investigators later determined she
knew Thompson prior to the shooting on
the recording Cummins can be heard
yelling for her to return the taser but
she does not give it back
come on
the Fight Continues ending only when
Cummins opens fire
everything
immediately Cummins puts in a shots
fired call as the woman on the scene
begins screaming
[Music]
[Applause]
Cummins again puts in another call
reporting that Thompson was only shot
once
[Music]
I need a union
hfd I'm okay so let's break a shot one
time First Responders gave Thompson
Medical Aid on the scene but he was
later pronounced dead at the hospital
after the shooting Abraham was arrested
and charged with interfering with public
duties the officer involved shooting is
still under investigation at this time
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie